all right let's keep taking calls the
lines are packed pat pat is going crazy
over there because we've got 11 11 lines
right now Pat can barely contain himself
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's take our next
caller from the 585 area code I have a
suspicion about who this might be and it
would be very exciting if it is indeed
who I think it might be caller from 5 8
5 name and where you're calling from
Christopher Henley from Rochester New
York
oh all right Christopher listen it's
great to hear from you at the Eggman the
Eggman calls in from the same area code
the Eggman is in the same part of the
country as you but it's not the Eggman
but this is just as good this is just as
good what's on your mind today
Milo the immigration issue of multiple
things but number one I just want to I
found you about a year ago and on
YouTube by accident
and I have never found somebody to be
more thoughtful your ideas and and you
take on issues and it's not just issues
that you agree with it's issues that you
care about and you have an opinion about
that makes the discussion so much better
and entertaining at times as well so at
times entertaining I'll I can't imagine
well because you have a sense of humor
about things and it's not about not it's
you don't take enjoyment in the misery
of others you take this like kind of
like an older brother to some or the
younger one who says you know you may
want to think about this a different way
because these are the these are the
consequences of that thought process so
when you engage people who you disagree
with you don't come across as I'm
bullying you well I appreciate that I
appreciate that very much
all right so I'd love to answer a
question if you have one sure what do
you make of the Milo situation with
regards to the fact that his history of
being sexually abused and then actually
becoming the abuser later not sexually
but with regards to how he
has been handling immigrants and
handling other folks especially in the
trans community even on the Bill Maher
show and does this belie something even
deeper within some in the conservative
movement where they just kind of heist
the guy up and give them lots of fame
and fortune then tear him down well
listen I mean everybody victims of abuse
are impacted by the abuse in different
ways the reality is that there are many
Republicans who statistically speaking
were not abused in the way that that
Milo yu-na Police has has talked about
having been abused by a Catholic priests
who have very similar views about
immigrants or the transgender community
or whatever so just because one is is
abused as a child doesn't mean that then
they are going to have particular views
towards other groups of people and not
everybody who has those views has them
because or at least in correlation with
having been abused I for me the most
interesting aspect of the Milo debacle
which has now happened I won't rehash it
all now because we've talked about it so
many times but the most interesting
thing to me is Milo innopolis one of his
big things has been he's against
identity politics the way that the left
does identity politics as he perceives
it and many on the right including the
alt right and in other areas of the
right are against identity politics yet
the only reason Milo innopolis became
popular is because of his identity as
the gay man who has these views because
nothing about his views is particularly
unique or interesting it's a British guy
who is commenting in a conservative way
aggressively so about American politics
and about some broader issues that go
beyond American politics if it were not
for his identity why would he be
interested if why would he be
interesting to look at the right so it's
it's very interesting to me that because
of the identity politics backfire this
entire thing has sort of blown up in
their faces it's I mean in spite of his
wearing a nice set of pearls I just when
we saw him on Bill Maher show it's it's
also about the level of anger and hatred
they don't see
that what you do what we hear has
profound ripple effects across you know
across the pond so to speak yeah it's
frightening from the immigration
standpoint where so many folks who come
to his grandparents grandparents made
their way from Ireland and guess what
they lied she'd steal their way to get
down from from Ireland over to Canada
made their way into New York worked as
tailors worked in bars and they were
illegal and then eventually somehow so a
long way they became legalized yeah and
I find it astounding like you know I'm
getting ready for st. Patrick's Day
parade and when I hear folks from the
Hibernians and they go we got to stamp
out this illegal immigration I'm looking
around are going do any of you realize
do you remember your grandfathers and
great-grandfather's who came over
because of a famine yeah what absolutely
absolutely great point could not have
said it better myself I've got to run
thank you so much for the call really
really appreciate it hope to talk to you
again very very much appreciated